let's talk about bone broth does it work
well there's not a tremendous amount of
research out there a lot of people claim
that it works but
i think you just need to test it out for
yourself to see if it does work when you
have knowledge of something and you know
it's true
it's something that you personally
experienced yourself knowledge doesn't
come from second-hand information where
well i know it's true because i read
something in a paper or someone told me
it's true
it's true because i tried it out myself
and so if you have
gut problems
or
arthritis or maybe an autoimmune disease
you might want to try it because most
people do bone broth
for those two reasons but today i want
to discuss why
it may work for those two conditions and
these are just theories we don't know
for sure
but what is bone broth bone broth is
basically
this cooked down bone joints connective
tissue marrow
and ligaments and tendons and basically
you're cooking all this down to make
kind of a brew or a soup out of it and
then you're going to consume this liquid
and when you cook it you break it down
to these smaller elements and so you're
taking this protein this long chain of
amino acids and you're breaking it up
into smaller amino acids so it is easier
to digest
and assimilate and absorb into your
tissue so it's not just amino acids it's
a lot of different things when you're
making bone broth you know breaking down
bone into calcium phosphorus
a lot of other minerals and there's a
lot of other things in joints and
connective tissue and even fat soluble
vitamins that can be in this product now
we know um one of the amino acids called
glutamine
does improve gut the gut barrier and
bone broth is a good source of glutamine
now
autoimmune diseases
usually stem
from some gut
problem where you have this protein that
invades the
lining of your immune barrier your gut
and then your immune system starts to
inappropriately
tag
this is a
pathogen or a foreign body and now you
have
antibodies against this particular
protein and so you can have an
autoimmune disease against almost any
body tissue
now you can also have something called
molecular mimicry
where you have some substance that can
mimic a body tissue
where you have some substance like
gluten for example the protein in wheat
can mimic
the thyroid tissue so this could be one
reason why you develop hashimoto's which
is an autoimmune condition to your own
thyroid so you have that factor as well
but when we deal with arthritis for
example especially rheumatoid arthritis
it's an autoimmune disease and it
usually stems from the gut and so
anything you can do to heal the gut can
be good for arthritis there's other
types of arthritis conditions with other
causes you could have high iron which
can cause arthritis or a liver problem
or consuming too many omega-6 fatty
acids which then create inflammation
also a low vitamin d situation can
create
arthritis or joint pain or muscle pain
especially of the lower back or you can
have a hidden infection in a tooth that
can then go into the systemic
circulation and go the different parts
of your body and create arthritis or
heart problems or it can invade your
brain so if you're taking bone broth for
arthritis you really want to also find
out what is the actual cause of my
arthritis because if it's coming from
something like a liver problem or high
iron
bone broth is not going to work now i
want to mention
one theory that i have that could
potentially be the reason why bone broth
does help for joint pain especially
an autoimmune type joint pain situation
now if you think about what an
autoimmune disease is it's a situation
where your own body
has antibodies against its own tissue
okay they're called auto antibodies
so it's like your body has an allergy to
its own
tissue and it reacts against its own
tissue so we have this constant
inflammatory situation of the joint if
you have this this autoimmune condition
now dr royally back in the 40s came up
with this very interesting
this idea this concept
and it kind of goes like this let's say
you had an autoimmune disease of your
joints okay where you had some type of
antibodies that are attacking the
synovial fluid or the synovial joint or
the cartilage or whatever and you
consumed tissue from another species as
in bone broth that has similar dna in it
okay
and you consume this it went into your
stomach your own antibodies that are
attacking the joint they're called auto
antibodies
would then be distracted
and go after this decoy
it's a really brilliant strategy that he
came up with and so what you're doing is
you're creating a distraction
you're
causing this auto immune attack to occur
in another place in the body
and away from the joint that's being
inflamed
giving the joint a chance to heal and so
he found that if you did this over a
period of time
you can deplete these this store of
autoantibodies in your system and
improve autoimmune conditions and so he
came up with a lot of different
remedies for different types of
autoimmune conditions whether it was for
the thyroid or the lung tissue or
whatever and so his company called
standard process has these products that
end with pmg okay that that stands for
protomorphogen which is basically the
dna of something okay but another
species like in a cow for example so its
products would be like thyroid pmg or
overtrophin pmg but this is just one
theory that potentially could be true i
don't know if it's true or not but i do
know when people consume bone broth they
generally do feel better in their joints
so i just wanted to bring that up as
maybe a another understanding of the
mechanism but if you have gut issues
there's several things you need to do
number one
probiotics
or even better yet
doing fermented cabbage as in sauerkraut
or kimchi you can get a lot of
probiotics from that
also the diet that you should be on for
gut issues
should be
more fat okay in animal protein i'm
talking about animal fat and animal
protein okay that's
really good for the gut but the ratio
should be more fat to protein you don't
want to do lean protein with a gut issue
you want to do more fattier protein okay
so it would be like two or three to one
as far as the ratio of how much fat
versus protein so fatty meat fatty
sausage
things like that if you're gonna do
plants or vegetables i would recommend
cooking or steaming them because those
plant chemicals can irritate people with
gut inflammation definitely don't have
any grains or grain oils okay and i
would not recommend dairy eggs are fine
organ meats are fine
bone marrow is really good
one last point about bone marrow people
want to know can i take it when i'm
fasting i don't recommend bone broth
when you're doing intermittent fasting
however if you're doing a prolonged fast
let's say you're doing
three days four days seven days whatever
it might be helpful
to take some bone broth simply because
you're going to be in a situation where
you might need some of these raw
materials especially some of these amino
acids here and there and because you're
not consuming a lot of food you're just
consuming a liquid version of these
amino acid and other products i think it
could be a very temporary situation
where you're maybe you're going out of
ketosis and you get right back into it
and a true fast is a fasting and you're
not consuming anything else so if you're
getting like muscle loss of course you
would need more amino acids from that so
just a side note now there's a very
interesting uh interview that i did
with a doctor on leaky gut that would be
a really good next video for you to
watch okay
check it out i put it right here